[Musique]
bonjour bienvenue donc dans point de vue
et au sommaire quel point commun entre
marine le pen et richard ferrand eh bien
ils sont députés vont devoir se rendre
au tribunal
victoire du droit ou instrumentalisation
de la justice on posera la question à la
une également les embouteillages et des
déviations bienvenue à
colombey-les-deux-églises où les omh
multiplier en ce 9 novembre 47 ans après
la mort du général de gaulle et on
reviendra sur cette nouvelle offensive
féministe version lexical après
l'écriture la grammaire inclusive qu'en
pensez vous donnez votre avis sur le
player du figaro.fr c'est-à-dire l'écran
dans lequel vous voyez cette émission ou
bien sur la page facebook du figaro et
en attendant on demandera son avis à
mettre du ml olivier de son prénom
bonsoir liste des auteurs président de
la fondation nationale des sciences
politiques et présentateur de
l'indispensable médias polis sur europe
1 le samedi matin et auteur du non moins
indispensable
macron et en même temps avec laurent
bigorgne et alice beaudry face avoue
christophe de vox spécialiste de
rhétorique et d'idées politiques et la
synthèse de ce savoir un aperçu du mois
et bien on le déguste dans réformer quel
discours pour convaincre
sylvain courage rédacteur en chef à loc
bonsoir et enrhume de l'ops cette
semaine cette enquête sur la chute d'une
icône de plus exactement d'un gourou
tariq ramadan et caminus était notre
soir joris au figaro magazine qui fait
sa une cette semaine sur ce week-end sur
la médecine préventive
on en reparle juste après cette émission
mais d'abord direction donc colombey les
deux églises 736 habitants au dernier
pointage mais un énorme embouteillage ce
matin illustration avec ce tweet de
notre confrère du monde olivier faille
bison futé voit rouge
a colombes et la tonsure la tombe du de
charles de gaulle acoyer à
over wauquiez à 9h30 philippot en fin de
matinée end et à salir nicolas dupont
aignan aussi mais pas en même temps
gilles lebreton fn à 12 heures c'était
précis mais il avait oublié geneviève
darrieussecq secrétaire d'état aux
anciens combattants
williams elle j'ai une question toute
simple à vous poser est ce que vous êtes
gaulliste non je suis pas gauzy non non
non non j'aime beaucoup général de
gaulle par ailleurs d'abord j'aime son
écriture
j'aime le personnage j'aime bien les
fous je trouve qu'il fallait être
complètement fou pour à londres en juin
40 dire la france et moi et et que la
suite de l'histoire vous donne raison
je trouve qu'il ya beaucoup de gestes du
général qui sont grands par ailleurs des
points que je désapprouve mais le
personnage l'aiment bien mais je suis
pas gaulliste nom christophe de l'homme
non plus décidément et tout le monde ne
sera pas gaulliste non le fameux dicton
mais même chose alors non plus et un
historien je suis sensible à la geste
historique incroyable et au fait qu' ils
appliquaient déjà de la lyre la maxime
de de son amie et rivale churchill en
ville à l'histoire lui est favorable
puisqu'il l'a écrite et il doit
notamment y pensait très savamment à
écrire ses mémoires
je pense qu'on va en reparler l'héritage
visiblement très très demandés et de
notaire aura du mal à choisir on va voir
juste cette gaulliste
non mais melox tout le monde est
passionné par son histoire par tout le
monde est captivé par le personnage et
puis c'est le double mètre étalon de la
grandeur pour les pour les hommes
politiques dont qu'ils essayent tous de
se mesurer à lui
peut-être que c'est ce qui explique son
succès
posthume on va y revenir car miss figaro
magazine vous êtes de la branche liga la
branche colis par esprit de
contradiction j'ai à dire je le suis pas
faire l'unanimité son plateau si on
parle de l'homme du redressement comme
les églises y e mail en 1940 qui à cette
folie de dire de partir à londres et de
dire je suis la france moi ça me va très
bien si ces mêmes l'homme du
redressement de 1958 qui dit attendez la
ive république court à la catastrophe
on va tout redresser moi ça me va très
bien donc de sur ces définitions là je
prends il y avait un professeur de droit
sa plaie qui était gaulliste de gauche
qui s'appelait d'abc et alors ils
diraient à aiguiser agonise de droite la
différence en trouvez moi c'est qu'on a
jamais et égoïste en même temps c'était
moi j'étais grossiste en quarts en pour
vous étiez petit risque
j'étais plus gaulliste en 45 voulait
devenu 58 voulais était à mort je
n'étais plus fashion que je suis
redevenu vous n'y était pas mais c'est
pas est-ce que c'est pas ça justement le
paradoxe c'est la force de de gaulle
c'est que il sur l'histoire va être
au-dessus droite et gauche ce qui est
fascinant dans l'histoire du volley du
gaullisme c'est que de gaulle lui il est
resté et selon les moments de l'histoire
occupait une place qu'on pourrait dire à
droite ou à gauche mais en revanche sur
son projet politique
il a complètement échoué c'est-à-dire
que la vème république organise tout
sauf le rassemblement part de la droite
et gauche macron nous fait oublier ça
mais c'est la cinquième république
c'est l'élection présidentielle qui a
refait la structuration droite gauche et
qui a recréé un vrai régime des partis
finalement et macro et micro ex list
macro il est ma chronique dont qui les
bonapartistes il est gaulliste il est
tout ce qui est grand parce qu'il est
n'a pas une vocation européenne et pas
trop gaullistes comme la modestie n'est
pas son fort en général donc cela ils
égalisent mai
rien mais oui sur l'europe non sur
l'europe sont pas tous les deux
finalement un peu maquillée médias au
sens noble du terme c'est à dire
justement ce que vous avez dit les
changements en fonction des projets la
phrase que je préfère chez de gaulle
c'est les choses étant ce qu'elles sont
et je crois que macron et très des
choses étant ce qu'elles sont la seule
la seule étiquette que je revendique et
gaullistes qui élit sa question tout le
monde sûrement guaino est probablement
philippot à un moment et qui d'autre
part la liste doit être tous les deux
années mais là en l'occurrence je
pensais à bruno le maire s'est justifié
ah oui exact le maire d'en bas c'est
commode dans la situation dans laquelle
il est en tout cas c'est à dire quand on
est passé du parti républicain des
républicains et parfois même plutôt à la
droite de ce parti a rallié macron dire
classe politique et de ces gaullistes
assez commode ou karl quelque chose de
jamais il y en a plus chez magro
insolent diène et non mais il y en a
plus je suis macron pourquoi parce que
macron a toujours considéré qu'on était
en 1958 quand il préparait sa
candidature avec son prénom c'est alors
ça l'arrangeait aussi parce que ça lui
permettait de faux de dire que si on
était à 58 ça veut dire que l'on était
rené coty ce n'était pas très agréable
mais donc ça lui permettait de 8 ce
n'est pas chez de françois hollande et
en même temps de dire il faut tout
reconstruire
il n'ira peut être pas jusqu'au bout
mais en tout cas il a opéré la première
partie de son programme en se
débarrassant d'un certain nombre de
participants certain nombre de figures
et de ce point de vue là on peut dire
que l'huile l'est pas ça c'est très très
juste
par delà les mots c'est vrai que l'idée
de macron de rassembler part de la
droite et gauche étaient totalement
gaullienne et d'autre part la seconde
idée qui est quand j'arrive au pouvoir
je doive très vite mettre en place est
effectivement le plus grand nombre de
changements possibles ça aussi dans
certaine manière on n'avait pas vu ça
depuis alors dans un genre très
différent mitterrand 80 mais sinon c'est
très très rare qu'un président les i se
réfère à se disputer les premiers mois
gaullien mais c'est pas gaulliste sentir
quand il ressuscite la participation
quand il ressuscite la participation il
fait référence à de gaulle peut-être
qu'il fera un référendum en tout cas ils
menacent d'en faire un sur les sur les
institutions dont qu'il a assimilé la
pratique gaulliste du pouvoir chez moi
il ya un gaulliste qui sommeille je suis
très attaché à l'héritage du général de
gaulle qui aiment ça votre bonne réponse
d'olivier duhamel crédible ou pas bon
pourquoi pas cazeneuve comme ministre de
l'intérieur
certainement pas dans ça fait devant pas
dans le l'éloquence hausse de 15,9 autre
nature ans et tu mettrais aux autres
races du tout mais dans le souci de
l'ordre dans certaine façon de dire les
choses comme le bon sens populaire il ya
pas mal de points communs et le 15 9
version 2005 car il était gaulliste
merci en 2005 irene qui refuse quand
elle est et saint louisiens et qui
refusent le jeune homme sur les îles et
sur le nom mais très vite il passe
proche de françois hollande dont qui il
arrive sur le oui côté je change de jeu
changent de position ça aussi c'est un
peu gaulliste
sinon oui ou maquereau nist en même
temps on tourne autour un peu du duo
parle beaucoup du style et on a raison
et on a du mal à parler évidemment du
contenu du gaullisme parce que justement
il ya eu tellement de contenus parfois
même simultanément du gaullisme et
surtout surtout les enjeux même sur
l'algérie après tout il ya eu des
conceptions très très évolutive du
général et sur voilà et et sur l'europe
après tout il a été finalement
pragmatique plus qu'autre chose
puisqu'il l'a laissée il a quand même
mis en place tout on pensait qu'ils
allaient sortir de l'europe il a quand
même mis en place le marché comme un don
qu'il ya je crois qu'il faut être et moi
c'est moi j'ai plutôt une analyse encore
une fois machiavélienne du personnage et
sa politique autour de quelques grandes
idées bien sûr et qui à mon avis ça fait
penser à la figure d'un homme
providentiel c'est aussi pour ça que
beaucoup de dirigeants politiques s'y
réfèrent c'est que voilà c'est l'homme
qui tombe à pic dans toutes les
circonstances étaient encore un point
commun d'ailleurs on débloque dans le
livre que vous avez eu la gentillesse de
mentionner et qu'on recommande vous êtes
encore plus gentil notre jugement et
précieux qui est très intéressant c'est
dans le fond de gaulle est obsédé par
l'idée de redonner à la france un poids
dans mon de remettre la france 2 que la
france soit pas de puissance moyenne
comme disait giscard et qu'elle retrouve
une partie au moins de sa grandeur et
c'est ça qui font de sa réforme
institutionnelle de l'institution en
soit c'est très intéressant c'est
l'homme qui a le plus mis les
institutions en priorité mais pas par
passion institut jeunes parce qu'il
considérait que c'était la condition
pour avoir un état fort qu'ils soient
dirigés ils pas aller au tas fort
permettrait à la france l'heure est
grave voyez macron macron c'est
exactement la même chose macron il dit
que irez-vous pas réformé redresser la
france seulement pour la croissance
pourra avoir démérité mais pour que la
france puisse devenir leader européen le
leader qui conduit l'europe a pesé sur
le poids du monde c'est le même
raisonnement toutes choses égales par
ailleurs
vous dites schéma quand il ya une vision
internationale une vision géopolitique
qui préside à sa vision politique c'est
très clair et qui est qui a alors la
différence et qui passe par l'europe
dans le monde dans lequel on joue à bhl
mais le lit des deux grands force et la
grandeur renault nick de la grandeur à
la france et d'ailleurs si on va plus
loin
- qui suivront je veux redonner de la
grandeur à la france ça au fond des
choses
c'est ce que pense de gaulle et c'est
quand même de loi qui a fait la
réconciliation vraiment avec l'allemagne
donc il a aussi été un européen alors
alors attendez je ne pousserai pas
d'imprudence jusqu'à rappeler qu'un plus
illustres que moi fit en son temps la
distinction entre perdre une bataille et
perdre une guerre et lança bonjour à
colas
je rends les armes bon gaulliste de
gauche mélenchon
non non trotskiste de droite on pouvait
lire pas plutôt vous retrouvez dans
cette définition c'est très bon parce
que mélenchon et est encore plus mégalo
que de gaulle alors jusqu'au bout on a
fait quand même un peu un petit tour
d'horizon va continuer mais on voulait
quand même refaire à une question de
court qu'est ce que le gaullisme et bien
la réponse d'un de gaulle
yves de son prénom petit fils du grand
père du grand charles
on écoute l'action de la pensée et la
vision du charles de gaulle c'est un
tout c'est un tout qu'on ne peut pas
diviser en petits morceaux où chacun
peut prendre celui qui la range et en se
coiffant du petit chapeau correspondant
est camouflée derrière une étiquette de
gaullistes les petits arrangements les
combines où les ambitions
donc ceux qui s'en réclament ne peuvent
pas comme ça simplement dire d'ailleurs
un petit morceau qui m'intéresse le
reste ça n'est pas ça charles de gaulle
c'était beaucoup plus que simplement
l'amour de la patrie
d'accord d'accord envie de dire comme le
tacle de lui-même à picorer dans le
gaullisme et que donc c'est un peu
compliqué s'annonce sûr je comprends que
ça l énerve que l'abuseur notamment je
vous propose d'ailleurs d'écouter
quelqu'un d'autre qui se les accaparer
je m'y attendais pas ce matin c'était
nicolas belmas président du front
national
lorsqu'on peut être on peut être attaché
à certains aspects la politique du
général de par votre corps en suisse en
l'occurrence moi j'ai une vision assez
gaullienne de ce que peuvent être les
relations internationales ou même son
économie sur l' équilibre entre la
nécessité d'un état qui protège
l'économique et en même temps la liberté
économique les libertés notamment en
matière fiscale et merci jean baptiste
bon c'était voulait réagir à cette
déclaration de nicolas bay poser une
question qui fâche est ce que le
gaullisme finalement ne réside pas chez
ceux qui l'ont combattu et notamment du
parti d'extrême-droite ces questions que
vous connaissez bien il est lui-même qui
sont une question européenne mais ça
monte surtout l'incroyable conformisme
de nos politiques parce qu'aujourd'hui
ça fait bien de dire que général de
gaulle d'une grande figure qu'on a des
points d'accord sérieux avec le général
de gaulle
mais en même temps le concert à ce degré
de généralité de banalité de ce que dit
nicolas bes ça ne dit rien sur les
questions internationales notamment
quand même ça veut dire qu'il est pas
belle d'ahmed pas dit la question
européenne
il aurait pu dire j'ai la même vision
d'une europe des nations et pas d'une
europe fédérer intégré il a pas dis
simplement il est divers l'international
sous-entendu derrière ça ya donné par
oui et puis devenait pas chercher sur la
russie parce que comme de gauche je veux
un point d'équilibré entre les états
unis et la russie
enfin il va pas développer de façon
suffisamment à télévision bien qu'il
soit intelligent
on lui a pas donné beaucoup d'occasions
dans cette interview que j'ai écouté ce
matin mais je pense aussi que c'est pas
non plus c'est pas le même fn peut-être
pas répéter toujours ce qu est l extrême
droite
du coup christophe mais ce qui est
intéressant dans cette interview nicolas
bay s'est concentrée que ça lui arracher
quand même un peu les tripes de dire du
bien du général de gaulle on sentait que
c'était pas sa tradition familiale ce
qui est quand même une partie on peut le
dire de l'extrême jusqu'à même chez
certains gaullistes
aujourd'hui le seul fait d'être
gaulliste c'est d'être contre l'extrême
droite
c'est donc c'était ça le csk pas un
paradoxe mais car oui alors on peut même
pousser le paradoxe encore plus loin
parce que en l'occurrence j'ai vu
florence portelli tout à l'heure qui
elle ne fait pas le pèlerinage à
colombey les deux églises
contrairement aux deux autres candidats
à laurent wauquiez et maël de calan en
l'assumant en disant moi je vais pas
aller je suis pas gaulliste c'est pas du
tout ma tasse de thé 'cela va y ait des
républicains
en quoi est ce qu'elle est pas gaulliste
pompidou on veut parce qu'il n'est pas
assez libérale sans eau il ya peut-être
deux non mais vous ont par ailleurs
nicolas bay c'est le racheta figure de
dire du bien du quiconque haute que
marine le pen lui-même donc c'est pas
spécifique au général de gaulle non ce
qui est vrai c'est que chez mary
peut-être plus chez lego liens que chez
les gaullistes ou chez les gaullistes
authentique et profond aujourd'hui ce
qui était frappant de soi c'est que de
leur point de vue aussi la frontière
avec l'extrême droite est absolument
doit être absolument imperméable et
regardez le nombre de gens quand entre
les deux tomes
dupont aignan a fait alliance avec
marine le pen le nombre de gens qui ont
dit pour un gaulliste c'est inacceptable
et donc ça il y avait quand même cette
idée c'est quand même les gens qui ont
voulu tuer le général au sénégal algérie
voilà celle à l'ombre de la guerre
d'algérie fait que l'extrême droite une
partie des stewards et est toujours de
gaulle et l'ombre de l'attitude
l'extrême droite avec de gaulle fait que
les vrais gaullistes des tests extrême
droite le temps le temps passer et ça
c'est la vieille extrême droite qui est
toujours forte au front national
je pense qu'en effet que nicolas bay
marine le pen sont peut-être sur
d'autres
vous n'aurez charles de gaulle petit
fils du général de gaulle était sur la
liste de jean 19 jean baptiste nous
avaient rejoints en tout cas il ya
d'autres personnes qui se sont réclamés
de l'héritage du général sur twitter
aujourd'hui oui alors commençons par un
premier tweet ça commence par en 1944 il
nous a conduit à la libération et à la
victoire
en 1958 il nous a épargné la guerre
civile et il a donné à la france
actuelle et ses institutions et son
indépendance équidés qui twitte ça et
bien moi j'ai la réponse c'est la
députée bérengère paix au titre et c'est
pas la seule à s'être fendu de tweets y
en a michèle alliot marie bernard acoyer
qui ont mis des photos à l'appui avec
une fois une très belle photo du général
de gaulle sur le perron de l'elysée une
autre photo avec un dépôt de gerbe
florian philippot lui propose clairement
une réflexion sur la pensée et l'oeuvre
de charles de gaulle effectivement il a
quand même prévu si ça fait quand même
de nombreuses semaines qui avait prévu
qu'il allait ce jour là aujourd'hui à
colombes et les eaux des digues deux
églises le gaullisme revendiqué nicolas
dupont aignan lui politis tout de suite
ne comptez pas sur moi pour alimenter le
jeu politicien et reprend les dires du
général de gaulle petit souffle sur les
petits feux donc forcément ils
politisent un petit peu le moment ce que
c'est quand même un rendez vous
l'éditorialiste eric brunet alors
celui-là vous n'avez pas dit tout à
l'heure vincent s'énerve il s'élève
contre les pathétiques embouteillages de
politique à colombey les deux églises
pour l'anniversaire de la mort du
général de gaulle ras-le-bol de la ras
le bol de la gaule o mania ajoute-t-il
et s'énerve carrément c'était beaucoup
aux tweets et d'ailleurs et enfin un
petit peu d'ironie alors je sais pas si
vous savez mais sur twitter quand
quelqu'un décède ou disparaît ça fait
bien dans les trending topics sur les
mots qui reviennent le plus et donc
thomas qui dit j'ai vu général de gaulle
en trending topics donc un démo qui
ressort le plus une fois de plus et j'ai
eu trop peur de lire qu'il était mort
mais général de gaulle était un bon
président il doit se retourner dans sa
tombe de voir sa france se ruiner il
doit dire quelle chienlit c'est ce que
nous dit christiane en ce moment sur sur
facebook un commentaire sur ces tweets
notamment sur celui de christian je
crois que dans tout ça il ya une chose
de beaucoup plus profonde et de beaucoup
plus collective qui est la nostalgie ce
que raoul girardet que nous aimons aussi
je crois
appelez le mythe de l'âge d'or de gaulle
c'est aussi les années 60 c'est la
croissance c'est le retour à la paix
civile
c'est l'explosion finalement là d'une
france en effet on a l'impression
qu'elle correspond à son image et ses
essais d'une période d'ordre et de et de
prospérité
comme disait le général lui-même c'est à
dire ou à la fois on pouvait faire la
fête mais en même temps la prospérité à
la maison et je crois que cette cette
nostalgie travaille encore beaucoup la
france comme la nostalgie de la
troisième république dans le domaine de
l'éducation
je dirais que le gaullisme sert un petit
peu aussi de mise d'âge de l'âge d'or et
on le voit bien à ce tweet et à ce vous
avez montré avec ce regret évidemment
d'une époque révolue mais c'est le
propre de toutes les époques l'être un
jour révolue eh ben on va tourner la
page on va revenir à 2017 merci jean
baptiste marine le pen devant les juges
bien ce sera bientôt aussi on a décidé
le bureau de l'assemblée il a levé
l'immunité parlementaire de la
présidente du fn s'est tenue hier et
avec richard ferrand qui est visé par
une plainte d'anticor on se pose une
question est ce que la justice sert à
affaiblir les politiques alors on va
d'abord s'intéresser au cas de marine le
pen
avant de parler même de ce pourquoi elle
est poursuivie la question on va aborder
la question j'aurais on aborde la
question de l'immunité parlementaire
il est normal de la levée c'est en tout
cas ce que pense et ce matin françois de
françois de rugy
le président de l'assemblée nationale on
écoute en l'occurrence notre ligne et
les constantes
c'est que l'immunité parlementaire ne
doit pas servir à faire obstacle au bon
fonctionnement de la justice et nicolas
bay le vice-président du front national
étaient diamétralement opposées dans son
approche en écoute des juges ne sont pas
au dessus de la démocratie et du
suffrage universel
je crois qu'à un moment donné il ya un
principe de séparation des pouvoirs qui
doit pas donner un pouvoir absolu au
juge par exemple sur le législateur
votre avis professeur duhamel
eh bien oui 12 surprendre je suis plus
de la vie du col a b que c'est françois
de rugy
alors laquelle doit écouter quoi mais
commente l'immunité parlementaire est
conçu est nécessaire pour protéger les
parlementaires dans l'expression de
leurs opinions et dans leurs votes
autant il faut lever l'immunité
parlementaire si quelqu'un est
poursuivie ou s'il convient d'enquêté
pour des délits de droit commun a
fortiori pour des crimes mais quand il
s'agit hélas il s'agissait de diffusion
de photos violentes sur des gens il ya
le problème de 7 à voir
elles seront floutés parce que justement
on m'appelait il ya le problème de cette
incrimination qui est vagues dangereuses
et où je veux dire le nom c'est une
question d'interprétation enfin le
nombre d'imagés violentes mais il n'y a
aucun doute sur le fait que dans la
diffusion de ces images
marine le pen n'appelait pas à ne
faisait pas l'apologie du terreau idéal
question tout le contraire contrairement
au contraire elle voulait dénoncer
dahesh et montrer l'atrocité de ce que
ce après je sais donc l'expression d'une
opinion expression d'une opinion avec
les outils du 21e siècle donc avec une
image et twitter mais ça aurait pu être
et à 30 ans une interviewé des mots et
je pense que dans ce cas là il est
légitime que l'immunité parlementaire
protège toute personne même celle avec
avec le plus grand des accords c'est à
dire en l'espèce marine le pen c'est
vraiment c'est un délit c'est une
utilisation politique de la levée
d'immunité qui n'est pour moi pas
acceptable mais sylvain courage
mais une opinion parce qu'elle répondait
à un journaliste jean jacques bourdin
qui avait comparé le front national a
déj
une manière évidemment outrancière elle
a montré ce qu'était la la réalité la
plus violente de dèche en disant est ce
que vraiment le front national c'est ça
donc elle disait quelque chose aux
portes du point de vue de la liberté
d'expression
c'est son boulot en quelque sorte elle
défendrait son parti après l'a fait en
diffusant des images qui sont proscrites
donc mais on voit bien qu'il ya
effectivement là quelque chose qui est
contestable je reviens juste à la
question précédente silva c'est la
soumission du politico juridique surtout
ce qui dérivent droite
j'imagine qu'à l'obs quand même on est
plutôt pour pour cette ligne-là non ben
c'est pas c'est pas évident parce que en
fait on a beaucoup de problèmes en
france avec la justice la politique les
les procès se font en dehors des
prétoires puisque c'est souvent la
presse qui instruit les affaires quand
il y en a les jugements sont rarement
prononcée donc on a quand même un vrai
sujet là il faudrait poser les choses de
manière plus plus clair qu'aujourd'hui
ce que je pense que les français ne
comprennent plus comment ça comment ça
se passe comment comment on incrimine un
homme politique et comment un homme
politique peut se défendre parce qu'il
ya aussi la question de la présomption
d'innocence de de la manière dont ils
doivent ou non démissionné des fonctions
qu'ils occupent tout tout ce champ là
est perturbé et je pense que du coup
avoir une position arrêtée aujourd'hui
est très difficile tout à fait dans le
sens et là je crois qu'on est au cordeau
tour de stade peuvent peu favorables à
marine le pen mais franchement moi je
suis je dirais carrément choqué je vais
même plus loin qu olivier duhamel je
suis choquée parce que imaginons le même
raisonnement
elle a diffusé aux jeunes d'être plus
simplement d'accord avec moi détendu
voilà je rajoute celles non mais par
exemple penser je pense à cette chose à
cet argument quand même qu'ils seraient
très puissant et qui à mon avis est
d'actualité l'utilisera qu'est ce qu'on
dirait si on accusait si on lançait des
poursuites contre quelqu'un qui
diffusaient des photos des camps de
concentration nazis en prétendant que
c'est une apologie de la violence
vous imaginez la situation c'est à dire
que ou alors qu'il est évident comme on
l'a rappelé comme vous l'avez rappelé
tout à fait d'accord il est évident
qu'elle dénonce dèche d'accord donc au
nom de ces atrocités
donc si on poursuit le raisonnement il
devrait être
interdit de diffuser des photos des
camps de la mort puisque ce serait
considéré comme une apologie de la
violence
voyez un peu dans quel mode de
raisonnement va moi je suis pour les
raisons liées historiquement à ce qu'a
dit olivier duhamel sur l'immunité
parlementaire qu'il est justement fait
pour empêcher qu'on poursuive un député
dans ce cas et en plus permis non
politiquement mais elle va se régaler de
cette affaire elle va gagner en justice
si elle ne gagne par la justice
française mais la cour européenne des
droits de l'homme dans les 15 secondes
de lui donner raison
nancy devra prendre la décision
rapidement et parce que la jurisprudence
et m selon claire soit la liberté
d'expression d'autant la parlementaire
on va véritablement vers quelque chose
de totalement contre-productif c'est à
dire qu'on peut avec cette affaire la
remettre en selle veut pas un peu loin
quand je pense que ce qui est quand même
très important
je crains qu'une partie de vos
spectateurs se disent mais que ces zozos
qui se disent tous pas gaulliste et puis
qu'il advienne tous défendent marine le
pen
nous ne défendons pas marine le pen ne
nous sommes pas le pénis et nous avons
un plus grande admiration pour le
général de gaulle et parfois marine le
pen j'ai pensé à vous accusez de
beaucoup de choses et des duels mais pas
de ça non mais n'est jamais venu à
l'esprit ficelles c'est quand même un
problème parce qu'il ya des gens qui ne
distingue pas des positions de principe
et en l'espèce à qui ça s'applique et
kid abba cissé pour marine le pen
asseyons-nous sur les principes ben non
ça c'est pas sur les principes parce que
c'est marie lemay alors pourquoi vous
vous comment vous expliquez que au
moment où a été soulevée cette polémique
qui est ancien hein
perdre personne n'est dit à manuel valls
ou à bernard cazeneuve qui ont lancé ce
moment là que l'on dénoncé marine le pen
en disant mais parce qu'ils n'osent pas
parce que le conformisme là encore je
vais avoir l'air de défendre marine le
pen parce que les gens sont pas
courageux parce que parce qu'ils voient
là parce que la distinction que je
rappelle entre les principes et à qui on
l'appliqué c'est pas la chose la plus
répandue dans notre pays vous savez que
donc ici sont lallaoui surprendre la
marine le pen super bien sûr etc
voilà pourquoi car je vous faire réagir
mais juste en vrai qu'on écoute
justement baladé face à ça va venir je
voudrais qu'on en entende la défense est
bien de quelqu'un qui est l'ancien
gaylib sylvain chenu qui il est vrai est
devenu depuis député fn elle met sur la
table ce que les autres ne veulent pas
voir
on lui enlève son immunité bon ménage
mais on lui enlève son immunité star ou
ayant quand même oui arrêtons là on l'a
bayonne ont dix ans comme on l'a fait
pour gilbert collard d'ailleurs on voit
que c'est réservé aux députés du front
national uniquement député du front
national madame au bono par exemple de
la france un soumises à des propos
contestables lorsqu'elle prend la
défense d'islamo fasciste elle à son
immunité
on va voir s'il ya des plaintes
la difficulté s'est classée 2 pincées
pas deux poids deux mesures mais c'est
il faut qu'ils aient des plaintes pour
que le juge demande la levée d'immunité
parlementaire elle se fait parce qu'il
ya un juge qui a demandé à ce qu'elle
soit levée je ne sais pas qu'est-ce qui
a lancé les poursuites contre marine le
pen
ah oui c'est qui a demandé pour pouvoir
entendre marine le pen
et si elle veut pas aux besoins avoir un
mandat d'amener
mais voyez très bien je relance que vous
disiez la défense de marine le pen
le tweet qu'elle a qu'elle a fait passer
il est ravageur au moment où il ya tout
ce débat sur les jihadistes partis en
syrie qui veulent rentrer en france
on sait bien là elle simplifie beaucoup
finalement il vaut mieux être un
djihadiste qui rentrent qui n'est pas
inquiété
ce qui n'est pas le cas mais bon elle va
simplifie plutôt que quelqu'un qui
dénonce les crimes de dèche et là ça ça
a un impact sur les gens
les faire comprendre aux gens tout
partie d'entre eux qu'il est légitime
que le frère de mera bénéficie de tous
les principes d'un état de droit mais
que marine le pen elle ne devrait pas je
veux dire il ya un moment où il faut ça
va pas de soi le maintien d'un droit
pénal civilisé le maintien du respect de
l'état de droit le médecin la
présomption d'innocence le maintien de
l'immunité sur ce qui est l'expression
des idées par les temps qui courent ça
ne va pas de soi le secret des attentats
se multiplient ou en tout cas elle
persiste les gens ont peur ça ne va pas
de soi donc raison de plus pour être le
plus rigoureux possible entendez
françois de rugy tout à l'heure qui
s'est exprimé ce matin sur france info
il disait également mais de toute façon
si ça se trouve il y aura pas matière à
poursuites ou comme cela donc en fait on
disait qu'elle aille devant laquelle
haye devant chez le juger s'il ya là si
elle est sûre de son bon droit pourquoi
ne le fait pas bah hautement pour
françois de rugy
il n'y a pas de délit de petitesse de la
zone de cerveau disponible
s'excuser en rigueur du droit
un argument non mais c'est le genre
d'argument vous savez qu'on attendait
que je trouve toujours très inquiétant
si on poursuit aussi comme on finalement
quand on a rien à se reprocher pourquoi
refuser d'être écoutés mais le genre
d'argument puisque après tout elle peut
aller devant le juge elle sera peut-être
disculper non la question si une
question doit-on déclencher une
procédure pour une dans ce cas de figure
je crois que sa masse est d'accord pour
dire que c'est contreproductif même vous
faire rebondir sur ce que disait
sébastien chenu juste avant est-ce que
voilà il ya que marine le pen qui subit
ce genre de rigueur
aujourd'hui oui on va voir vous avez
expliqué que tout à l'heure et qu'il va
y avoir une plainte déposée contre eux
richard ferrand
on va voir s'il de ce point de vue là
pareil le bureau de l'assemblée lève une
immunité parlementaire si ça va j'ai
plus loin en tout cas ici nous sommes
quelques esprits libres aux attaches ou
c'est pour ça que nous allons profonde
relativement différentes qui peuvent
s'accorder sur ce point mais est ce que
vous avez entendu regarder des images
que vous avez passé mais au delà
est ce que vous allez retrouver une
personne qui ne soit pas du front
national de l'univers politique monté au
créneau pour dire qu'on n'aurait pas dû
lever l'immunité par alors c'est pour ça
je pour aller plus loin c'est pour ça
que je suis étonné de vous entendre ce
soir et qu'on n'ait pas entendu ce genre
de voix quand la polémique a éclaté
le deuxième round richard ferrand donc
justement effectivement vous le lisiez
karl risque d'être de retour devant la
justice cette fois ci c'est
l'association anticorruption anticor qui
porte plainte
voici le motif invoqué par son président
l afp ce matin nous attendons
l'ouverture d'une instruction pour qu'il
y ait un procès car nous ne sommes pas
d'accord avec l'analyse du procureur de
brest alors le procureur de brest avec
classe et la faire sans suite la faire à
leur monte à 2011 quand richard ferrand
était directeur d'un mutuel de bretagne
et ils avaient loué des locaux à une
société appartenant à sa compagne le
parquet a estimé qu'il n'y avait pas d'
abus de confiance qu'il n'y avait pas
discret d'escroquerie et que l'affairé
était prescrite
en un mot ce que dit l'association
anticor d' qu'on entend depuis ce matin
c'est que le parquet a pas fait son
boulot mais nous on va faire on va faire
le boulot c'est olivier vous trouvez ça
normal est pas tout le temps intervenait
en premier juriste de lavande
non je ne connais pas assez bien le
dossier c'est pas dans quelle mesure on
peut recommencer
la procédure je crois que c'est
l'interprétation du délai de
prescription sur la prise illégale
d'intérêt si je me trompe pas oui ça
c'est ce qui est effectivement un des
arguments avancés par antibes n'ayant
pas étudié plus que cela je sais pas
quelle est sa pertinence peut y avoir un
petit problème aussi sur le fait que
tout ça a été traitée par le parquet de
brest
une certaine proximité on va dire avec
l'intéressé et pas par le parquet et
financier national qui lui par
définition est plus indépendant donc je
n'ai pas d'avis très tranchées faute
d'une connaissance plus complète du
dossier ce qui veut dire que je ne
critique pas anticorps mais qu'à ce
stade je n'ai pas les éléments pour
l'approuver désolé de ne pas toujours
avoir un point de vue tranché
est-ce que christophe est ce que vous
trouvez pas justement que pour le coup
là anticorps au moins dans la posture
est logique
ils ont reproché anticorps d'être une
association qui s'en prenaient que aux
élus de droite
là oui je crois que d'autre part ils ont
ils ont recouru à vous savez où un juge
d'instruction du coup puisque le
procureur le parquet avait avait donné
un non lieu donc ils sont passés par le
juge d'instruction avec constitution de
partie civile qui est la seule façon en
droit français de relancer une affaire
je pense que juridiquement on verra
malheureusement pas du tout compétent
même si je connaissais le dossier pour
juger du fond d affaires mais il est
certain qu'un appartement où il ya un
doute
moi je suis moi même principe même
traitement d'accord c'est à dire que on
avait on a fait pour françois fillon
rappelez vous il ya pas si longtemps une
enquête très rapide très vite ouverte à
partir d'un article de journal
il ya eu le même article du même journal
d'ailleurs sur sur monsieur ferrand on
est obligé de constater que les les
poursuites ont été engagées
beaucoup plus tard c'est à dire après
l'élection est obligé de constater aussi
qu'elle se sont terminées par une
nullité ce qui est sans doute qu'ils
étaient enfin des beaucoup plus tard
mais pas il a fallu une pression et
c'est une pression médiatique mais ça
lieu avant l'élection puisqu'on l'a même
dit qu'il avait des bus
oui législatives il est peu importe oui
pour nous entraîner l'ouverture un trade
et ça soit après l'élection
présidentielle
prix 20 présidentielle vous disais juste
un nom sur balles quand même était le
grand sujet c'est à dire que donc ce que
je veux dire par là c'est que c'est la
fameuse expression vous avez la femme de
césar ne doit pas être soupçonnée
ce qui ne veut pas dire que le parquet
ait fait des choses horribles ce qui
veut simplement dire c'est qu'il doit
être mis dans une situation irait
prochain à priori
or vous le savez ça vous parlez du
parquet du compaq et la compagne de
richard ferez et non derrière
l'occurrence pour la faire en plus comme
telle qu elle avait résumé un peu plus
bon brumeuse que ça il se trouve quand
même ne rappelons le quand france le
parquet n'est pas indépendant
contrairement à ce qu'on nous répète
toute la journée que la cour européenne
des droits de l'homme nous le rappelle à
chaque régulièrement et je dis pas te
parquet albanais que le parquet hobby le
pouvoir politique et son la chancellerie
dans des affaires d'un des lieux ils
n'ont jamais eu d'instruction j'en sais
je n'ai pas dit je n'ai pas dit qu'il
est ce que vous avez dit laisse entendre
et fait comprendre par tous et non pour
une fois on va se friter oui c'est sûr
que le parquet n'ait je ne dis pas ça si
je dis que les dépendances une affaire
que ça suffit maintenant non dans les
mandats sont juridiquement
institutionnellement le parquet n'est
pas indépendant dont ça ne veut pas dire
qu'il a reçu des instructions mais quand
vous n'êtes pas quand vous n'êtes pas
indépendant organiquement de quelqu'un
ou d'une institution
il y à une suspicion sur votre sur votre
liberté c'est aussi simple que ça ouais
enfin maintenant toute l'évolution
récente montre que les parcs et les
procureurs et autres font un peu près ce
qu'ils veulent
le vrai un autre problème qu'on pose pas
parce qu'ils se posent pas directement à
chaud aujourd'hui mais qui est un
problème quand même considérable qu'on
n'arrive pas à résoudre qui est très
compliqué c'est la coexistence des
procès médiatique et du procès
judiciaire et aujourd'hui quelqu'un qui
prêt dès que quelqu'un est mis en cause
il est l'objet d'un procès médiatiques
parfois dans des conditions très
choquant cela parfois on ne demande même
pas le point de vue de l'intéressé
taille qu'on publie des choses qui
mettent gravement en cause de notre
quelqu'un sont même avoir demandé sur
l'épisode ce que je trouve totalement
scandaleux
et le procès médiatique pèse beaucoup
plus que le procès de dix ans si vous
perdez un procès médiatique et vous
gagnez pour ces judiciaire deux ans
après ça n'empêche votre honneur a été
détruit or tout c'est ce qu'a dit
richard ferrand dont louis et toute
l'histoire des allées n'allons pas
chercher trop loin mais en tout cas des
50 dernières années sont celles de
renforcement des droits de la défense
dans le procès judiciaire toute
l'histoire on va développer on va faire
principes constitutionnels
on peut pas mettre en cause l'avocat est
sûre le procès médiatique 0 regarde
parce que c'est compliqué puisque ça met
en cause de la liberté d'expression moi
je trouve pas besoin de la présomption
d'innocence à la fin des années 90
on devrait mettre comme règle par
exemple qu'il est totalement réfractaire
dit de mettre en cause une personne sur
une affaire sans demander son point de
vue à l'exposé ce serait élémentaire en
principe cela les paroles et à l'ops ça
fait partie de l'éthique journalistique
mais c'est vrai qu'il ya pas de
d'obligations non ce sujet sur la
plainte dont enfin la procédure lancée
par anticor il le dossier qu'on le
connaît quand même le le procureur de
brest il avait entendu toutes les
parties
l'histoire elle a été détaillé il faut
il va falloir comme qui trouve des
éléments nouveaux en dehors des
arguments juridiques sur la prescription
hors ya un problème dans cette affaire
c'est que les mutuel de bretagne ne sont
pas plaignante
or elles sont censées avoir été lésés
donc il ya quand même quelque chose qui
manque dans le pur pour que vraiment la
sphère prennent et je me demande du coup
si la plainte d'anticor pour vraiment
prospérer françois de rugy ce matin
disait qu' il y en avait assez un peu de
toutes ces plaintes
inutile certes ravi également vous qui
avez su ce qu'elle remake est assis sur
d'autres
à d'autres moments à que vous pensez
donc je donne mes sous titre carl meeus
a suivi la campagne de françois fillon
c'est tout l'accord passé en
l'occurrence dans et du coup ça nous
amène sur les reins brisés qui s'est
lancé pour voir redevenir ministre à
l'occasion d'un possible remaniement
après le 18
novembre et les élections oui ce sera
une élection à main levée de castetner à
la tête dedans marche ça risque de
s'éloigner de nouveau parce que on sait
pas grave de toute façon pas traitées
d'ici le 18 novembre
et il ya quand même un risque même si ce
que vous avez dit donc on sait pas ce
qui se passe françois de rugy a raison
dans ce que vous gagnez le pen
exactement dans la m est ce qu'on
appelle une contradiction absolue lors
de visites au loin qui parle pour pour
la république au marché alors que le
prénom l'assemblée nationale devrait
être normalement au dessus de d'une
mêlée politique mais vraiment vous y
croyez surtout pas françois de rugy
soutien c'était soutien castaner pour la
pour la présidence mais c'est ça le
problème c'est qu'à un moment on attend
des hommes politiques qui soient à la
hauteur de la fonction qu'ils occupent
là dessus c'est vrai que quelqu'un comme
philippe séguin occupait bien sa
fonction
vous avez vu qu'il y avait quand même du
client qui a porté plainte contre sa
voyante parce qu'elle lui avait annoncé
que dans quelques mois et elle est
décédée
saleh avait gravement perturbé donc en
effet de parfois arvam jeu de l'oie
géant est prévu ainsi la voyant si la
voyante l'a pas vue elle peut être
poursuivie pour responsable si la mort
n'est pas survenu il ya un grave
préjudice exact il nous a poussés à
richard ferrand que ils vont perdre
[Musique]
donc on dit les voyants ou les voyantes
sont odieux ou les voyants ou les
voyantes sont odieuses d'ailleurs c'est
une question des hommes et des femmes
sont belles où les fouilles hommes et
les femmes sont beaux mais le christophe
spécialistes mais j'ai mon latin
qui fut bon on est un peu anciens mais
on dit un peu tout et n'importe quoi
actuellement en guise de latin et c'est
l'accord de proximité c'est un peu plus
compliqué que ça parce que quand le sud
comme par exemple dans votre exemple ou
l'adjectif et attributs et bien c'est
masculin qui l'emportait en latin on va
pourvoir en perdre son latin
car on va essayer le pédago un collectif
mais un collectif de 314 prof demande la
fin de la règle de grammaire selon
laquelle le masculin l'emportent sur le
féminin c'était sur le site slate.fr et
ce n'est pas du tout du goût de jean
michel bancaire ils n'ont pas droit il
ya des oublis il ya un système
d'inspection à l'éducation nationale qui
fait que si un prof de professeur de
mathématiques dit que le théorème de
pythagore n'existe pas ou si un
professeur de français a dit que telle
règle de grammaire n'existe pas alors
qu'elle existe
il se met en faute évidemment donc il
prend le risque d'être sanctionné disant
les choses calmement le risque
effectivement de problème alors jean
michel blanquer rajouter même qu' il y
en avait assez de massacre et je cite la
langue française c'est est ce qu'il
disait déjà hier moi je veux bien mais
là mais mais la demande est parfaitement
en règle avec les
en accord avec les règles académiques
christophe de boxe et pas c'est pas trop
mouillé tout à l'heure mais il ya la
règle de proximité le genre et le nombre
d'un objectifs s'accordent avec le nom
le plus proche est une règle qui date de
l'époque de boileau et de sylvain
courage quand même avis à loeb ce sens
et grammairien du xviie siècle qui sont
sur la sellette parce qu'ils ont
beaucoup masculiniser apparemment je
sais pas non plus un expert mais ils ont
beaucoup masculiniser la langue
française notamment les noms des
professions mais aussi les règles
d'accord et donc il ya tout un mouvement
de contestation voilà alors sa soeur
quand même à dire et disent que le
masculin des il est à la fois le
masculin et le nôtre oui mais la langue
française ça pose quand même des
problèmes regarde l'évolution de la
société
parce qu'il n'ya pas de neutre parce que
les adjectifs s'accordent parce que
partout finalement la langue est sexuée
et on voudrait aujourd'hui que ces
différences sexuelles ne s'exprime pas
dans le langage est donc on est on a un
outil qui est très imparfait et qui va
pas aider à ces évolutions à ce ass
concrétiser donc je pense que cette
question à la leyre anecdotique mais
elle ne fait que commencer à se poser
non ce que vous êtes en train de dire en
fait c'est qu' il faudrait pas utile
utiliser la langue française pour
justement lutter contre les stéréotypes
de genre c'est ce que disent les
féministes oui vous êtes d'accord
écoutez moi je suis très très contre
l'écriture inclusif donc ça atroce
je trouve que c'est en plus ça complique
énormément les choses donc c'est aussi
un truc où on pourrait dire de classe
qui va rendre encore plus difficile
apprentissage de la langue telle qu'on
doit la parler parce qu'ils ne sont pas
dans des milieux culturellement
privilégié en tout cas à lire c'est un
minable de voir tous ces points eux etc
je suis en tête alors que c'est censé
être fait pour simplifier voilà selon
les dans la chaussure terminologie en
revanche j'ai appris ma part je suis pas
du tout
savant malheureusement autant que je
devrais dans l'histoire de la langue
j'ai appris que autrefois et jusqu'au
xviie siècle donc sans motif ouais on a
vu large maman est allée jusqu'au xviiie
la règle de de proximité s'appliquait
donc c'est pas en soi scandaleux je
trouve ça assez normal tout ça me
dérangerait pas du tout et ça massacre
pas notre langue puisque notre langue a
été parler comme ça pendant des siècles
et ça se compliquerait pas au delà de
même je dirais plutôt que ça
simplifierait parce qu assez souvent les
gens font des fautes dans cette règle et
ne l'appliquent mal donc je pense qu'on
peut pas mettre sur le même plan la
question de l'accord de proximité et
l'écriture inclusive et parce que si
l'on simplifie trop
et alors tous les gens un peu
traditionalistes au respectueux de
l'allant pour être sur une position puis
tous les féministes ou ceux qui courent
derrière sur l'autre non c'est trop
simple un jeu mettre un euro dans la
machine je vous donner la réponse en
fait par anticipation de natacha polony
qui était l'invité des rencontres du
figaro c'était mardi soir salle gaveau
on écoute et avant les accords se
faisait avec l'adjectif le plus proche
on peut entendre en effet qu' il a
existé d'autres formes de la langue
française
pour autant on revient ton en arrière
c'est tout de même curieux que les gens
qui sont les plus modernistes et qui
nous explique que le passé est
absolument épouvantable que évidemment
dans le passé les femmes étaient
opprimés souffrait terriblement toutacoo
découvre que dans le passé finalement la
langue était un peu plus féministe alors
on a vu l'argent le site de cette partie
par la reine
la règle est décelé depuis le 17e siècle
s'il de l'éloquence la parole et donc
aux spécialistes des discours m
christophe des vols vers là je suis pas
je suis pas pour autant un philologue
mais moi je suis tout à fait d'accord
avec les idées générales qu'il ya un
problème notamment la fine il a su
féminisation des noms des noms de deux
professions
tout ce que vous avez évoqué moi je
trouve que vraiment il faut voir ça
justement avec un peu de sérénité ne pas
rester sur des positions académique au
mauvais sens du terme
non mais dans ce que dit le chat polony
est ce qu'il ya par oui elles pointent
ce qu'on appelle en rhétorique la
contradiction de l'argument adverse et
et mais cela dit je suis tout à fait
pour qu'on réhabilite l'accord de
proximité à condition encore de quoi
qu'on sache de quoi l'on parle
l'accord de proximité c'est terne
c'était justement sur pas d'exemple que
vous donnez les hommes et les femmes
sont belles ça n'a jamais existé en
france ait jamais quand l'adjectif je
reviens ce que je disais était attribué
c'est toujours le masculin qui
l'emportait nous avons rencontré loup
des hommes et des femmes très belle
alors voilà c'était là qu'on avait
l'accord de proximité quand l'adjectif
est l épithète vous voulez qu'on parle
qu'en soit savant mais je veux dire ce
qui m'a ce qui m'intéresse là dedans
c'est justement des gens échangent des
arguments souvent peu fondées qui sont
les arguments très très très joli livre
est ainsi au fort passé sauf les
progressistes alors à la zone de cerveau
disponible quasiment inexistante aucun
ne considère que tout le passé était
introduit sa demande lui dire une
connerie pareille même pas par monsieur
pourquoi vous pensez que ça oblige tout
le monde à faire de la grammaire mais
certains cas car le vainqueur n'a pas
répondu moi je me mets à la place de la
grammaire inclusif ou pas non mais moi
je me mets à la place de nos enfants nos
petits enfants
est ce que nous on a appris voilà c'est
le masculin qui l'emportent
eux ils vont apprendre selon les profs
une règle ou une autre une incrétines
inclusive ou une autre et donc quand ils
passeront le brevet ou le bac selon les
correcteurs et c'est la même c'est la
catastrophe par les photographes ne sont
plus sanctionnés plus très loin oui mais
là on est plus dans leur temps car on
est 40 plus dans quelque chose
d'idéologique quand on voit ces
professeurs l'a acquis qui lance cet
appel on est quand même plus dans
l'idéologie et quand on va déjà qu' il
faut dire monsieur madame le ministre
madame la ministre
parce que quand vous voulez kg quand
vous êtes lycéens collégiens ou
vous savez pas si vous allez faire une
photo pas et fait penser au sens vous
une dernière une dernière chose comme ce
que disait sylvain c'est à dire est ce
que vous pensez qu'il n'est pas
nécessaire je sens de revenir à 7 à 7 à
cette règle pour lutter contre
l'inégalité ce qu'on appelle les
stéréotypes de genre dans la novlangue
salon est de lutter contre alors
question subsidiaire
bon alors question subsidiaire beaucoup
plus sain parce que c'est dans l'actu et
je voudrais une réponse courte de vous
tous
la grande roue de marcel campion est
menacé d'être enlevée en 2018
encore une querelle homérique entre le
roi des forains et la reine anne hidalgo
faut élever la la grande roue de marcel
campion c'est la question d'ailleurs
composent le figaro.fr
moi je vais faire de réponse je dois oui
je le principe de contradiction est
interdit c'est à dire un lieu quand
marcel campion décide de lutter contre
la mairie de paris il va bloquer les
routes et donc ils emmerdent les
banlieusards et absolument pas les
parisiens
là c'est un paradoxe je ne comprends pas
c'est comment y êtes contre marcel
campion la deuxième réponse oui il y
avait un petit problème il fera mieux de
bloquer paris voilà la deuxième réponse
jeudi
quand on va à londres on va tous voir la
grande roue de londres
on trouve ça merveilleux on y va à paris
ce serait peut-être pas mal c'est
peut-être pas celle de marcel campion
qu'il faut c'est peut-être pas à cet
endroit là enfin la grande roue de
l'ondh
elle est en phase ii de westminster est
en phase de big ben tout le monde trouve
ça très beau et elle est beaucoup plus
grandes heures moi j'ai une nouvelle
passion dans ma vie depuis trois ans et
demi c'est ma petite fille anna je suis
allé deux fois avec elle sur la grand
roue de la concorde et c'était magique
pas trop cher est une réponse
ce n'est même pas tellement j'étais
content pour un débat de près il
faudrait une grande roue illégal parce
que celle campion l'a installé sans
autorisation au départ c'est une
occupation du domaine public et donc
anne hidalgo se venge de la controverse
sur le marché de noël en maintenance
attaquant à sa roue et cette bagarre est
un peu ridicule mais c'est vrai quand
même que marcel complot s'est assis sur
pas mal de règles et donc la grande roue
oui mais essayons de respecter les
règlements et les lois sur les voitures
il ya de la place à pleuvoir je vous
dirais que c'est voilà un sujet sur
lequel je n'ai aucun avis que je n'ai
c'est de la très compétents c'est pas
très bon en arrêt jarre est gentil si la
discussion merci beaucoup
il ya quelqu'un qui a un avis sur tout
dire c'est celui avec qui vous avez
rendez vous même un sujet inattendu
eric zemmour qui nous parle bien d'un
sujet que vous allez découvrir juste
après point de vue et je vous le promets
jeudi prochain vous retrouver maria
mélinand barre et alexis boisée autour
de cette table merci beaucoup merci de
nous avoir suivis et vous restez bien
sûr sur figaro live jusqu'à 20 heures ce
soir
[Musique]